introducing the new
non-discriminatory
language guide
the british council edition
brits
don't use when referring to people from
the uk
makes fellows from northern ireland feel
excluded
guys
associated with men and can be perceived
as excluding women
time to bring back good old ladies and
gentlemen
native english speaker
relates to countries like the uk the usa
and australia
and discriminates against others
not so native speakers from other
countries rejoice
developing country
use lower income country middle-income
country fragile and conflict-affected
state
feel free to be more specific
british english or queen's english
implies that these varieties of english
are more correct or of greater
importance than others
too bad nobody but the brits really
thought like that
oh wait what about the british council
better start looking for another name
before it cancels itself